there's never been a better time for
your Police Department stock up on
military grade equipment tons of
equipment and the Pentagon wants your
department to get that equipment for
free we've the nice sticks to those
pussy-ass Bobby because here at the
Pentagon's 1033 program everything we're
talking Bearcats thanks today launchers
m16 rifles everywhere here yes oh bomb
body armor torch utility vehicle spine
Resistant Ambush Protected vehicles
ovaries bird the airplanes bomb defusing
robots
little to no training at all and more
chocolate run then everybody can even
hello got some BS demonstration yes that
thing got a jaywalker chase him down
with a free helicopter oh you think your
towns too small for a tank or all we've
given tanks to Fargo North Dakota Story
County Iowa and Keene New Hampshire got
a Strawberry Festival you need a tank is
your town having music in the park you
need a tent got a community theater
production of Twelfth Night
you needed the tank good sir it's a free
tank we gave away half a billion boom in
gear last year and we're ready to give
away good deal apply to the Defense
Logistics Agency at this way
hundred-number below the 1033 program
bringing local police departments
military-grade equipment from our war
zone to yours
god bless america
you